prime minister draghi
dear mario ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much for joining us from
all the different places
we are in this together and we have to
work together because
as we all know no one is safe until
everyone is safe
we have to join forces to fight this
pandemic from
every angle and to recover sustainably
and this is true for health authorities
and all levels of government
it is true for scientists universities
and pharmaceutical companies and it is
of course
true for civil society ngos and
foundations
philantropists and international
institutions
people like you people who are dealing
with
global health challenges on a daily
basis
this pandemic has shown to us that
health
is a true global public good
and this is why the italian g20
presidency
and the european commission decided to
host the global health
summit on may 21st in rome
and this is why we want to hear from you
before we discuss how to prevent future
crisis
how to prepare better and how to become
more resilient
in an area of pandemics
they are important questions to address
what is needed to ensure
effective multilateral cooperation
when responding to a global crisis like
this health crisis
what can we all do to ensure that all
countries big or small with higher with
low income
have the necessary capacities to tackle
the next crisis and
last but not least how can we mobilize
the necessary resources
on a global level billions of people
around the world
urgently wait for answers not only to
fight this pandemic
but also to be better prepared for the
next one
in the european union we have started to
prepare
while also drawing our lessons
with our hera incubator we want to get
ahead of the curve
in the next phase of the virus for
example by boosting even
further our production capacity in
europe
not only for europe but also for the
world
just as we are doing right now with
vaccines that are being delivered to
europe
and vaccines being exported around the
world
we are accelerating the development of
vaccines therefore we are stepping up
research and data exchange
between science and industry
and we're speeding up the approval
procedures because
as in any crisis time is of the essence
it's important that we all learn from
each other
our joint ambition must be to achieve
the same level of preparedness
at a global level and this is why we
need
your input your ideas your expertise
and your passion and therefore once
again
i am excited to have you all with us
today
thank you very much for joining and i'm
looking forward to your contribution